so just take me from that first moment
that you decided you were going to
become a Muslim to how your mindset
changed to you committing crime what
happened I guess everyone is different
but for me it was when I first become
Muslim I'd say the first six months to a
year was just normal going to the mosque
and you know I'm saying praying and
fasting and whatnot but then after a
little while you know getting more
involved into like activism and stuff
and propagating Islam and speaking about
Islam in public today I'm moving on to
more controversial things such as the
Muslim patrol and confronting people I
guess where my beliefs became more sort
of I have to do physical have to
physically implement my religion rather
than practice here personally on a
spiritual level sort of propagated and
implemented on other individuals that's
when it become more of going out and
stopping people drinking and stopping
people holding hands and being outside
the mosque dressed in certain ways
that's when it become more like you said
the crime that's of it so that process
how did you how did you get to that
point obviously it sounds like it was
gradual yeah I guess it was in terms of
the end process sort of to the to the
facts of committing crime so there be at
the beginning not just praying but there
was always the belief after as it
started sort of process and my belief
become stronger and then I sort become
more con like I'd say convicting was the
almost correct
you know correct and was according to
Islam so when when that beliefs were I
was certain that I was correct and I
guess through some of the internet
lectures online reading certain books
and learning from certain individuals
all of that collectively the way it
affected me was convinced me to sort of
go out in public and do these things as
a propagation of my faith so the
internet played a part for you yeah of
course because you know I would I would
search certain lectures online and look
at certain people's videos online and
you know notorious individuals under an
out lucky I would listen to a lot of his
lectures and I guess it started off by
listening to the life of the Prophet the
life of Abu Bakr the Companions you know
then hear of the series paradise and all
of this then moving on to more political
issues like foreign policy
you know Islam jihad you know
all of this stuff then it that's when it
sort of I took them lectures which were
very specific and I made it generalized
then I sort of implemented that
understanding that I had to know why the
society and what were you thinking at
the time did you see yourself as an
extremist as this labeled extremist or
was there not the recognition no because
I guess somebody who makes mistake never
recognized they make a mistake until
they actually analyze what they've done
after they've done it so at that time
especially I had people around me
convincing me as well and sort of
certifying that what I was doing was
correct that's what sort of gave me the
conviction that what I'm doing is
definitely me
it's definitely calling to the religion
is definitely a propagation of my faith
how do you perceive now what you did how
do you feel about it well obviously I've
got mixed emotions about what I did
because you know I guess in essence
protesting is not something which is
which is you know forbidden in law but
when it breaks out into into civil
violence and all of that stuff that's
when it becomes more you know
controversial and and opposing the
majority of society's beliefs what I
guess my actions definitely in the
Muslim control was something that even
within Islam says it's incorrect so you
don't even need to look as a Muslim I
don't need to look outside my own
community to understand that my actions
were or something which were forbidden
and do you agree then that they're wrong
and if you like you repented of that do
you have yeah of course because I guess
personally repentance is between me and
God to say that he have to recognize
myself on us forgiveness on a spiritual
level but obviously from the outside of
the society to say look I apologize to
the individuals that I did harass and
attack and all of these people they
obviously does more in environment
around me to apologize to them but
definitely I always think about even on
a day-to-day basis if he was just forced
to search myself online you could see
the type of things that come up and it's
not something that now I've moved away
from there and I've studied my faith
corrected I understand these type of
actions are completely incorrect do you
feel ashamed of what you did
of course because I guess as a Muslim my
appearance would represent Islam so my
my when people see that they connect my
actions to the religion which now I
understand to be
completely correct and I guess it's
caused my actions itself has caused a
lot of Islamophobia a lot of backlash in
terms of the Christian patrol and
Britain first and the EDL and all these
actions they are directly from what I
done to the people and the individuals
at large so I guess you can say that
definitely it's something that's always
on my conscience and even though you
could say even if they those individuals
did forgive me and forgive what I've
done on a Muslim patrol and Edgware Road
I would still feel inside myself
something that of course other Muslims
harm and my actions at large of course
caused a lot of Islamophobia tell me
when you first had contact with this man
and your first impression were you
skeptical over what he was doing I first
met Woodsman through the Probation
Service upon my release from prison
and I was very skeptical when meeting
him because obviously the same people
that had imprisoned me
much of the justice system and then I'm
working with the Probation Service and
now introducing me to this person so my
first impression seemed as a Muslim was
somebody he was definitely spying on me
or he wanted to gather information from
me he somebody wanted to you know get
information out of me to pass on to the
police service and and and the Probation
Service so I was very skeptical as
someone who was a spy or somebody who
was trying to infiltrate the Muslim
community and that was my first
impressions of him and how did how did
that change how did that develop over
how long I guess when you meet anyone
the only way that can change your
perception of them is when you meet them
personally you sit down with them like I
met his children you know I'm a his wife
you know I met the people around him his
friends you know his family he's his
teacher all of these people you know
that that I'd learnt about and I had and
I had started to take my religion from
what convinced me that this individual
cannot be a spy as well as a practicing
Muslim they're two things that
contradict each other
so I said to myself definitely this
person who wants to help the Muslim
community but he's using the I guess you
can say the things that he has at his
disposal meaning the Probation Service
to help the Muslim community and also to
help society at large as well so in
terms of mindsets estimating the unity
initiative they talked about linguistics
and that oral tradition of Islam just
take me through how that like teaching
that ya perception you came to how that
changed
now you've just what you've just
explained that's a that's a traditional
teaching of Islam so like you said the
oral tradition is what how we learn our
religion and documenting it down is how
we learn Islam so when he approached me
with these teachings all I had to do was
basic research to understand that yes
Islam is too like this and and majority
of Muslims don't believe what I did was
correct so that like I said earlier that
I had to judge myself and question
myself and say to myself you know is
what I'm doing correct and it did happen
that I did go back to prison for a case
that was backtracked thank you before
that and then that's when that time in
prison I really had time to think and
reflect and I was me and wasn't on legal
visits you know once a week and was
speaking so all of that all of that you
know it's a combined made me start to
understand and it was a slow process it
wasn't I met him on Monday and by Friday
I was working with him you know it
wasn't like that it was it was over the
years spent in prison my second time
made me sort of understand that me in
the Imams in prison and going to Islamic
laws and speaking to other Muslims that
I sort of start to understand the wider
aspect of my religion not just what I
had taken for myself pick and choosing
the religion and so bringing it together
and acting upon that I started to
understand from my wider aspect that
this was incorrect and what they was
doing was actually in fact more Islamic
than any of my actions I had done before
so how would you summarize how your
perceptions changed what was it and what
is it now well I guess you could say
clash of society you know like for
instance to us and them thinking that
every non Muslim is my enemy and Islam
is a head at loggerheads with society at
large and Islam is not compatible with
the society which we live in so we have
to oppose him we have to stand against
him
these these this ideology that I was
taught before and the ideology that
understand now that Islam was compatible
when the Prophet he first received his
revelation he was working with the
non-muslims in that society and he was
teaching them about Islam by in a way
that was correct not just attacking
people because they don't agree with
what you believe in so when you were
part of the Muslim Patrol you had this
view that you wanted Sharia law to be
imposed in Britain blance changed has it
of course because mean the main aspect
of that belief is that I haven't got
authority to do so so me going around
attacking non-muslim
that have nothing to do with the say you
would say society at large like somebody
drinking alcohol has nothing to do with
the law implementing to say that alcohol
is fine so at that time I was to say
that I used to believe that and I still
do as a Muslim I disagree of these
aspects sort of I don't drink and I
don't smoke and I'm a man I'm a married
man so all of these beliefs I have these
principles as a Muslim but do I have to
implement them on others this is
something that I took me a little while
to learn and I had to look into it
deeply but something which now
understand is the correct belief is not
that you don't have to implement it on
other people and force it upon them